do anything you want to add no okay good
I'm done with this video
today's topic I've got a video I want to
show preach boom from my favorite TV
show they're real
for what it's worth they gave they added
these skin color emojis because other
people were not represented so you know
once again they started off with white
folks emojis and then we all had to wait
for others I started yellow are started
all yellow they were yellow and blonde
and the features were also yellow and
blonde if you know what I mean and yeah
they were just Caucasus you look like an
emotion Diwali which whatever it's all
good and so I think that there's
something to be said for just having
it just always feels icky to me what
people when people feel like they can't
show support without trying to replace
or without trying to appropriate and
that's just odd to me I'm so protective
of black culture and a black identity
because we have had such a continual
fight to preserve it and to get to exist
in it without chains so when I see
people just dabble in it like I'm black
your life I don't understand I'm black
and group chess but I'm not black so
wait using black emojis as a black
thanks no there's been a thing like that
digital blackface but yeah that exact
same reaction there was a thing like it
was it was it was a thing that was not a
thing it was an outrage they try to make
it an outrage but it wasn't it like
someone I think was something about you
know someone doing a pounds of someone
indeed it was a black person during the
pound like that you know I knew like
that and the other person was white
responded with a pound but that was
black and they got Carroll on it like
yeah that's black in that that's that's
digital black for some like on real
issues that is a non-issue that is not a
real thing to me to wait every time I
play an RPG character and nor would you
rate them yellow know or what am I go
because you're not the oppressor you
cannot so if a white person plays a
video game and they got a black avatars
job they're doing digital blackface yeah
so you are back white people you can't
play GTA 5 all the missions with
Franklin in it you can't do it yo that
is a non-issue that kind there's some
people that were super offended yet
together the bruit the same super
offended and they were even saying that
this would be considered like the
equivalent of texting blackface what are
your thoughts on that leave absolutely
this is very you know in the mix of like
Kim Kardashian putting on makeup that
darkens her skin you know and then
listen we know your shows trash no
amount of applause breaks is gonna help
okay
you're at home during quarantine it
sounds [ __ ] ridiculous
and then be like oh this is just makeup
and it's like it's that that's still
used altering your appearance because
the news yeah I see the problematic when
the Kim Kardashian does it when she
advertised something with the features I
understand but with the texting and
everything and stuff you're stretching
you're not yoga stretching this is
Taoism you have swings that yeah so
reach streetfighter stretching your
flames so this is bananas cringy digital
blackface but is using a black emoji
supposed to be cooler than using I'm
just trying to understand cuz I use a
lot I use cat emoji sometimes are you
trying to impersonate a cat so we call
you doji cat are you gonna please call
me just dawned on me bro I think I
realize why this bothers me I've played
RPGs my whole life I get to customize or
care yeah I would create hobbits I would
create dwars I would create elves with
long years different colors sometimes
I'd create a female avatar it never
dawned on me in that moment I was like
trying to impersonate or trying to
appropriate and I never thought other
people were trying to do that they were
just creating characters that they
thought were cool and that was it
but there some people are gonna try to
appropriate and do that like in life in
live gaming they're gonna jet they're
gonna chess as a bi preparation and
walking me that I'm not even saying that
it's bad or whatever but there are some
people that are gonna do that is it bad
good or bad it's not they're just
playing if the actual point of the game
so how is it appropriate I don't think
it is but you said what's that's nice I
mean that's what I've heard about the
issues of like that people are gonna
appropriate certain characters and walk
and talk and and that would be saber
night it's just an interactive movie
that's what a videogame isn't a lot of
kick which you are that character that's
it you get to customize and change
certain things but you're playing
through a storyline that's been built
for you that's all it is
so for me you choosing a character this
is not some recognition of like I want
appropriate I just want to play pretend
the same way when an actor takes on a
role and it's this doesn't necessarily
mean that the
that person does that make sense I know
what you're saying yes do you understand
how privileged you must be in the West
to whine about emojis MA
really yeah God digital black so wait
when I use a good when I use a gift yeah
yeah they actually use that example as
well if you use if you use a get yes
I've seen that brother all the world
people listen in the month of December I
deleted so many people of my facebook
because they were having this rhetoric
because they were I think this is this
thinking why you cannot use if you use
cuz there was a girl I remember this
conversation and there was a girl this
white girl she used a gift and the gift
was a black lady going like this and
another girl flipped on her awoke one
person flipped on her you cannot you
what she's trying to do it now I just
delete I just delete that person
throwing like you I legit I'm legit heat
it broke your how amazing that Michael
Jordan crying gif is to know that a
whole bunch of people are not allowed to
use no they not because he's black it is
one of the greatest gifts all the time
or how about the Laughing one where
Charles Barkley walks in and he bursts
out laughing it's one of the best gifts
one of my best gift is waka flocka flame
okay yeah okay well not by that little
white girl who's just like yeah Khloe we
can't you know no because it's digital
blackface or digital yellow-faced these
people are digital brown face it's like
you have no hobbies this is one of the
few times that I want to look at Amanda
Steele's is just that why don't you make
a video about that for watch you make a
video about that instead about this like
why are you talking about this huh about
that why don't you know about that you
don't mind you make a video about that
here's sounding like a seal shut before
I do not get it this is such a non-issue
this is such an honest and I find it
ironic that you are out here talking
about I'm so concerned with the race of
this and that when you got on Instagram
live and you lied about who teacher
there me party in their race
she was legit noble floki nobles with
low-key noble because she lied about it
you don't understand her that's the
thing that's her problem
you don't she was doing it for the car
therefore it's Loki noble even if it was
a hoax this is really happening all the
time and even if it was a hoax for the
sake of bringing attention to this then
I'm like that's Loki noble racism
because it's no get out of here with
your blond hair face like emoji look out
make a video about something else I
can't stand these people issue oh my god
I'm in this video yeah yeah yeah yeah
what's up Easy Bake Oven Easy Bake Oven
you don't get the call that [ __ ] I ain't
turning [ __ ] do do it damn you gay you
did this one
that's right no people can evaporate how
about that yeah yeah with this B thing
heat the fumes baby let the fumes it she
yes right with white folks emojis and
then we all had to wait for other
started yellow our guard at all yellow
yellow it's not the point
well should start off as my people she
said no they started off as yellow yeah
disagreeing with that it's just it
started with white people would attend
that's what it was not yellow was white
people it was white yeah really yeah I
never thought that way whenever I saw an
emoji I never thought this looks like a
white person's expressions are they
black are they Chinese they're yellow
they're yellow but they represent white
people do that cuz when they're black
people in there you see who's black you
fuse Indian you see use that Chinese no
I get that I get that but you know what
it is I think when I was watching The
Simpsons I never got a feeling of their
whiteness it was like at least
individual characters like Ned Flanders
smoked me as white because he he sounded
like but he was yellow yeah so
interesting okay me and Willy
the Willy the gardener of the school
he's caught ish yellow yeah that's
interesting
I wonder why there's probably an
animation reason for the reason why they
draw them yellow tease you know I think
it's just I think it was just that but I
would have to research it yeah I'm
pretty sure this must be a reason but
it's interesting to me because it never
cut emojis were yellow but it really
meant white people because yeah
yeah absolutely yes that comment to me
is like yeah you know what